you just got bamboozled Erte we're
talking about mirages and this apex
Legends guide the holographic trickster
what could you say is the quick summary
of this guy
yeah Mirage is basically a distraction
he's the master of the Juke he's a
character that allows you to be
unpredictable right it's a hit-and-run
tactician where arch is a very kind of
solo player in a way just based on skill
sets which we're about to go into
compared to all the other legends I
think it's safe to say that a lot of his
abilities or his three abilities are
kind of Awesome
yeah self-centered right yeah definitely
a solo player if not the most solo
legend of the whole lot in that his
abilities don't necessarily help your
team out maybe you could argue ultimate
the vanishing act where you send decoys
out maybe that's a good way of just just
again distracting an enemy so your team
can live to fight another day
but yeah let's just get right into it
his tactical psyche out what can you say
about this thing yeah so psycho it's
pretty cool you're able to send out a
holographic decoy that can then be used
to confuse the enemy the decoy can do
different things obviously if you kind
of point it far away aim it far away
it'll kind of like run off into the
distance if you crouch it'll kind of
simulate a crouching motion if you're
kind of like crouching and walking at
the same time so it can be really tricky
for the enemy to deal with some of these
psyche outs you know it operates on a 15
second cooldown so you should be using
it for the most part all the time in my
opinion like anytime you're in combat
firefights just starting send one of
those away so you can have the upper
hand and distract the enemy so you can
engage first and as you mentioned the
decoy will reflect whatever you're doing
so if you're sprinting he will sprint if
you're crouched you will Crouch you can
have them standstill because your
crosshair will pinpoint where he is
going so if you wanted some far aim a
little high and have them just run into
the open field and that's an interesting
tactic with psych-out is in my
experience like the later stages of like
a circle or say you know there's one or
two squads left and you're unsure where
they are you got a wide open range you
just want to kind of pry the area and
see if anyone's gonna give send a decoy
out into the middle of the field and see
if anyone will shoot at it then you have
the ability to then pinpoint where they
are because as you know that if someone
hits the decoy it'll give away
position basically puts this like little
running man icon above their head and it
kind of points in the direction roughly
of where they're shooting from which is
a great tell obviously so again that's a
use to kind of learn the enemy kind of
pinpoint where they are I would say for
the most part as mentioned you're
sending a decoy out to just simply
distract the enemy team and another way
of incorporating that is for flanking
right so an enemy sees you or if you're
behind cover
send your decoy out in one direction and
go the opposite way and and flank them
until you have ample time to again flank
the enemy that's a pretty good use for
it
another cool way of using the tactical
psych-out is in the very last stages of
the Ring I had this instance where it
was literally one guy left
I was not near my teammate said enemy
down my teammate I knew where they were
meaning I knew where this guy was was
right next to my down teammate opposed
to being right next to your decoy send a
decoy off first without you being seen
and then approach late into the
firefight so again the enemy is super
focused on your decoy and with a lot of
firefights if you are able to start
hitting first you will have the upper
hand
yeah I think a point that you made to me
before that I didn't really think about
necessarily it's just how can you kind
of mimic the decoy how can you throw out
this psyche out you know in a in the
same vein as if you were the decoy in a
way right like because that's really
what sells the opponent into thinking
like oh there's the Mirage and that's
when it gets like really deep I think is
when you can start using that psyche out
tactical ability in a way that really
kind of makes you feel like that's the
Mirage that's actually like there right
and you know there are uses too to have
your decoy just stand still but I tend
to find that a very obvious way for an
enemy be like oh that's a decoy because
he's just standing there right so again
aiming high and sending a decoy off for
the long run I think can can be more
viable than just having them stand still
right and then last a little bit about
the psyche out is when you drop in you
have actually two decoys at your ready
so if there's a hot spot and you want to
kind of push teams away from your drop
area you're giving the false idea that
there's a bunch of people landing and
hopefully they won't land near you
there's another use though with the
balloons I found Oh scatter across the
map yeah so it's really similar to when
you drop out of the dropship except
instead of two decoys you only get one
it's still a great distraction tool you
know let's say you're in trouble you're
kind of getting away from a firefight
you're like cool I'm going to take this
balloon shoot off that decoy so that it
buys you time makes the enemy have to
choose which one to shoot they're not
sure which one to shoot thus gives you
time to you know hopefully get away get
away to safety or just take less damage
yeah and I think one more cool thing
that we should mention is that you can
actually trigger caustic traps by
sending your decoy you know this could
be a nice cheeky play that you could
pull off to potentially you know lure
the caustic out and get some free shots
on them because he'll think like hey
somebody triggered my trap
up next the passive encore there's not a
whole lot to this is there when you go
down you basically kind of like leave
this decoy behind that like is like oh
I'm dying you know but your nacht still
but you're closed yeah five seconds
where you're actually cloaked so you
kind of get away find a nice crawl spot
or find a space away from enemies
the best-case scenario that I can think
of is hopefully you have a gold knock
down shield or something like that so
that you can get away and you know self
revive generally I happen to die near
enemies which makes it very easy for
them to kind of see me and kill me yeah
I mean I would agree with you like most
most instances where I go down the enemy
is very close to me so it isn't your
best interest to utilize all five
seconds and get out of sight get behind
something get under a house whatever it
is but in the off chance that maybe
you're really far away and the enemy is
unable to get to you quick that's a good
opportunity for you to find cover and
that's really from passive moving on to
the ultimate vanishing act allows you to
go cloak for about three seconds and
send out a whole bunch of decoys to
distract the enemy further there are
some good uses here one would be to
again in run tactician mindset fire that
and run away and live to fight another
day get some health in you and Arie
approach a fire fight differently any
other uses you think for the vanishing
act yeah it's definitely also good for
flanking you know you see an enemy team
that's far away maybe pop the ultimate
so that you can kind of engage your
cloak they probably don't see you you
can wrap around and hopefully get behind
them so that once you do finally
reappear you actually have your guns
ready and you can shoot you know the
enemy team now it is worth noting that
when you are invisible or cloaked you
cannot heal you cannot use your weapons
if you're seen by the enemy team guess
what they actually can shoot you and you
will take damage so it's not like you're
invincible or anything like that so you
want to definitely be mindful about how
you're using it definitely I think those
are the two distinctions is like if you
know an enemy is looking at you and you
fire off your vanishing act you're not
making a flanking play you're running
away you're gonna find cover and live
again to fight another day well that's
gonna do it on the sky for mirage we
have tons of apex legend guides so do
check out gamespot.com and stay tuned
for more guides down the road